i'm satore and i am working as director
of data analytics and data science at
diconium
and
i mean you can
check on linkedin and stuff like uh um
that i want to waste time on that but
decornium is actually um
i.t company working like the it's owned
by volkswagen so most of the projects
that we are doing is with falvey or
volkswagen
in case you are interested to know about
it um
yeah so i actually gonna talk about do
we really need data scientists today um
which actually i hope that i can answer
that question during this
20-25 minutes that i'm going to talk
and um but first i will talk about
actually what is the problem and
why am i actually going to talk about
this question and where it came from
and then i would like to give a little
bit of history of um of the data science
as a job where it came from and
how it emerged and the background of it
and
because i think it's actually helpful to
understand a little bit what is data
science what um where it came from and
what do we need to expect from data
scientists
and also at the end i would like to talk
about what is data science really and do
we really need them
um and
yeah so let's start so as i said i will
talk about what is a problem so um the
problem is actually that in the last
two years let's say that there are a lot
of online articles that i have seen and
many of you probably also might have
seen
that they predict actually the data
science job
and
they
they talk about the future of data
science is it going to vanish or not
or is it dying out
and for example i put now a screenshot
of one of them here on the left
says why machine learning engineers are
replacing data scientists but there are
actually a lot of examples of them why
she should become a data engineer not a
data scientist
or as i said like actually many other as
well
this third one actually
yeah i i don't understand i mean i read
the article i understand the content of
it but like data science feels like a
fake entrepreneur coach on youtube
telling me that the future will be
bright as long i don't know if you
understand it come to me later
explain me please but anyhow like as i
said like there are a lot of like titles
like will data science become absolute
in next 10 years is data science 30 10
years or not
so that is actually why i decided to
talk about it today in this conference
because
i i also assume that many people who
attend the conference are working
either as data scientists or close to
data scientists and that's actually the
question that's going around
um i actually read those articles and
tried to summarize like the arguments
and um i could summarize them in three
categories i think a lot of people in
this um and these articles like actually
they they gave the argument about
automated machine learning so that they
think data science and machine learning
tasks are now becoming automated and
there would be no need for data
scientists but more for ml ops or data
engineers another category of the
arguments is that over saturation of job
market that job market is flooded by the
people changing their job from other
background or jobs to data science but
also in the past years the graduates of
data science graduates like from
bachelor master also
entered the job market and that is also
one one argument over saturation of the
job market the third category is that
there is something greater which is
happening ai which we have been heard
about it for many decades actually like
that
it is happening and now we actually need
more application of ai in a setup data
science
so i would like you actually to to have
these three categories of arguments in
your head because i come back or refer
back to them as well in the talk
um so these are the arguments and um to
answer actually um to these arguments
and to think if they're correct or not i
decided to put a little bit of history
into our
actually perspective
and
specifically i mean i think that history
is in general very important about
anything any job or anything actually
when we are
trying to analyze it
but
specifically for data science i think it
is very important because of that the
job is actually not very old so looking
at the history of it it's not like
looking i don't know how many years ago
it's just like a couple of decades that
we have this job
so um i started actually
since um actually from 1960s when the
power of computers started to become
like changing and like it was a rapid
like
involvement actually in computers power
or computational power
and
also it was in 1962 that jw tukey wrote
about like an article the future of data
analysis so it was actually the time
that the whole shift for mathematicians
and statisticians happened like on on
data analysis
and
i actually really love that photo on the
left because of many reasons i mean this
photo is like showing us from 1962 and
it's showing uh four boards of like um
parts of like four early computers
from basically left to right um it's
like the four generations of the nsc
that the size of them getting smaller
the computer boards um but
there's actually another thing
interesting in that photo for me is also
of course that
actually the ali like in in a couple of
decades ago the the people who have been
these people who have been holding the
boards um they were like most it was a
very female job um working with
computers and uh it's very interesting
that how in a short time it changed when
the money and like power started to come
like to the field of i.t and computer
that became a main job
but it actually started
differently by now this is not the topic
of my talk but i found this photo very
interesting
um it was in 1974
that peter niles who was
danish computer science pioneer who is
sorry
um
wrote a book in concise survey of
computer methods and
he mentioned that book
when he's
basically referring to
to what we think of data analysis and
then data science he referred it as
science of dealing with data so till
this point the data the term data
science was not being used but like it's
the first time like you mentioned like
the science of dealing with data when he
was talking about statistics and like
analysis of data
and then it was in 1976 that programming
language s was developed at bill
laboratories
um until then fortran was being used for
statistical like computation
i don't know if there is there are
people old enough as me to know fortran
um i'm actually much older than what i
look like
um yeah it was actually it is a fortran
it's a powerful also programming
language but anyhow like s was like
developed for that um to offer an
alternate and more interactive approach
ali design decisions that hold even
today include interactive graphics
design devices and also providing easily
accessible documentation for the
functions
so this bell laboratories actually
should have it
keep it in your mind like it's actually
they played an important role in over
like a couple of decades in the in the
field of um statistics and also like
industrial statistics and they're owned
by a nokia now so now i think that it's
called nokia bell labs i don't know if
they're that important now anymore but
but in the past like they were actually
and a lot of like great um
mathematicians worked at the bell labs
this photo is also from blair labs uh i
don't know if it is from 70s i think
it's from 80s but i find it also very
interesting i really love like um
looking at old photos and analyzing it i
don't know if they pose for that photo
or not but
it if they didn't it seems that he's
talking about like something which he's
very passionate about one of them is
very interested the other one is a
little bit suspicious the guy on the
left i don't know or angry even and the
woman the lady there oh my gosh she's
bored
she's really poor i i have a feeling
that she's like okay leave me alone i
want to work um
but um yeah anyhow i find this this
photo also very interesting um
yeah so um in 1991 uh our programming
language r which was an open source
implementation of the s
was developed by statisticians ross
ihaka and robert gentleman from
new zealand university of auckland and
um as we know probably most of you know
that r is still being widely used in the
in the field of data analysis and data
science
and um yeah it has been used actually
much more it is now like a lot of
companies like or a lot of research
centers
prefer python but still r is being
used also a lot
and in 97
the term data science is being born
basically professor j.f jeff wu calls
for statistics to be renamed data
science and statisticians to be renamed
data scientists
professor jafu
born in 1949 is still working as a
professor at georgia institute of
technology he's from taiwan but moved to
u.s after his initial studies in taiwan
and he's known for his work for
on the convergence of the em algorithm i
don't know if you know it's very
interesting
it is exception a maximization algorithm
and re-sample emitters such as the
bootstrap probably mostly heard of it
and industrial statistics i actually put
this information there um because um
to just not forget that the person who
used first time the term data science is
still not just a lie but also is it
working
and that is actually
like a point for me for this like a
slide that actually how
young is still this this job as like
data science job
in 2001 cleveland published data science
and action plan for expanding the
technical areas of the field of
statistics and to cleveland
this was also very interesting for me to
read that because nowadays actually we
are a little bit different like on on
the definition of jobs to cleveland
actually data analysis is good at
programming but has limited knowledge of
the statistics a data scientist on the
other hand comes from a statistical
background but has to work more closely
with computer specialists
this is actually like yeah
yeah he also worked at bell labs as you
can see also on the screenshot of the um
top of the photo
the paper
and
yeah so
that was also a very important article
in its time in 2012 probably you have
heard of it like
dj patel a very actually
important person and also thomas
davenport they wrote this data scientist
and sexist job of the 21st century and
this article was being circulated a lot
for years
from the article i quote that more than
anything
what data scientists do is make
discoveries by swimming in data it's
their preferred method of navigating the
world around them at ease in the digital
realm
they are able to bring a structure to
large quantities of formless data and
make analysis possible
make analysis possible that's actually
also um interesting to see like where
actually when when it was the hardest
job or success job
uh what how it was being described by
the experts
so um now to have like a little bit of
history in our head
i would go to the next section or last
section that what is actually data
science nowadays and do we really need
data scientists
for that i have a lot of ideas myself
but for preparing this talk
i decided to ask to make a very small
survey and ask people in my network who
work either as data scientists or
related to data science or data science
managers is there anyone here who
answered my survey actually
okay two people laughs nice i'm sorry if
i interpreted your answers wrongly
come to me afterwards if that happens
um i just sent this um very short i
don't know you needed like three minutes
to fill out like a couple of questions
um i know that i mean as a data
scientist i know that i kind of like
generalize the answer of the survey um
from actually 65 people um to what it
exactly
really is involved
but i think it gives like a little bit
of like idea to us so um 65 people
answered my survey 40 of them were
working or are working as data
scientists 20 of them as data science
managers and team leads and five other
working with data scientists so i
actually split these five people based
on their job for example like one was
data analyst who had worked as data
scientists before so i put in the
category of data scientists or one was
like a data science teacher i put in a
category of managers so just like try to
split these five people in the answers
all of these people have worked like or
63 of them work for european companies
and mostly for german companies so that
is also for me important to mention here
because um because i don't know how it's
in china i don't know how is in u.s it
might be different um what i know from
my experience and people around me is
mostly from like actually germany and
european companies so
um that i also want to also emphasize
here
so
the first question i asked actually what
are data science tasks to you
and here i want actually to it was a
multiple choice question as well i tried
to write very long sentences
to to get like an idea of like different
fields i didn't want just to put data
analysis or i don't know what just to
because then it was maybe yeah to to
really think of like to see how people
think of the tasks data scientists who
answer this question the most popular
answer like which around like a bit more
than 80 percent of them chose is
extracting information from data using
statistical knowledge and programming
languages example python and r it was in
parenthesis
the second
answer was supporting business owners
translating between business problems
and data solutions oh well
fair and the third answer data analysis
with scientific and research background
then designing models and deploying them
i emphasize and deploying because we
have also afterwards designing machine
learning algorithms and validating them
and then we have implementing ml models
and producing an api endpoint of the
model for the engineers
so the first three which are the most
popular ones i've tried actually i try
here to focus on as answer of the people
who work actually as data scientists
right now
and um to compare actually with data
science managers who most of the data
science managers i'm also one of them
myself like we worked as data scientists
so i was very surprised to see like
there is a very big difference of the
answers of the people who lead the teams
of data scientists and the people who
actually work as data scientists so um
i
as i said like for data scientists these
three were like the most popular answer
extracting information using statistical
knowledge programming languages
supporting business owners understanding
like translating between business
problems and data solutions and then
data analysis with scientific and
research background
but then however the first three answers
of the data science managers is like
yeah they were just clicking on
everything basically as you see their
percentage is also high so but the first
one is design designing models and
deploying them so for them is the main
task of data scientists
designing but also deploying them and
then the second one is actually like
supporting business owners or cafe
designing machine learning algorithms
and validating i think also fair and
then there is
i want to focus on this one this is the
biggest gap so it was the main task
by actually stated by data science
managers but also
i don't know fourth one by the people
who work themselves as data scientists
and i think that's one problem that we
have
then i ask skills needed to get hired
from data science managers so if they
choose their managing teams they go to
this question what are skills you're
looking for when you're hiring and they
answer machine learning and algorithm
okay for mathematics statistical
analytical thinking great deployment of
models again as one of the main tasks
and data analysis and data visualization
field knowledge or domain knowledge of
the business familiarity with the data
databases and data warehouse and
non-live but still like that the ones on
top that i want to focus
and
then i asked them okay these are the
skills that you're looking for do you
actually find these skills easily
when you're hiring and um just six
percent of the data science manager said
that they find these skills easily like
more than 50 percent of 53 percent say
no i can't i can't find it and 41
percent of them said that um
well sometimes i have difficulties
finding them okay oof we should be fast
okay um
yeah that's actually also like one thing
that i wanted to pull out then i asked
where is the skill gap
so if you cannot find these skills what
do you think the reason is where is the
main skill gap and then again
we again come to that point because i'm
looking for data scientists who can do
the deployment as well or in general
have some skills in engineering
i don't go through the rest because
i think that is what i want to pull out
today again come back to it
then i asked data scientists is it clear
what you need to do is your task are
clear as a data scientist to do
more than 50 percent of the data
scientists answer to that service say
that it's not clear for them what their
task is
and just 47 percent of them said that
it's very clear i mean can you imagine
any other job like carpenter
electrical engineers that will say oh
it's not i don't know what to do i don't
know what my job is
yeah
as germans would say it is catastrophe i
think
it's really catastrophe
why isn't it clear so i asked him why is
it this was not a multiple choice
question so they could just i wanted to
understand what is the main pain point
so they could just choose one so the
ones that they said then it's not clear
they go to this question
and
the first answer is there isn't an
unrealistic expectation from data
scientists where i work at from analysis
in engineering
and then the managers don't understand
what data scientists can exactly do in
the company work at
there isn't much data
there
i don't comment that there isn't any
data science use case so um these are
like the how
yeah so i just go fast forward so
summary of the survey for me is that
difference of perception in data science
tasks so data science managers
see deployment i want to again make this
one bold as a main task of like data
scientists as
data scientists they don't do themselves
data science tasks are not clear more
than 50 percent of the data scientists
found it has gone clear skill gap
between the requirements and the job
market ninety percent of the ds managers
have problems finding the skills they're
looking for and there is an unrealistic
expectation i mean just to come back to
the skill gap to go back like that the
argument over saturation over saturation
of the job market i mean if we do have
over saturation of job market for data
scientists how data science managers are
not finding what they want to 90 of them
yeah so
and then unrealistic expectation about
40 percent of the data scientists who
find it has unclear
think there is an unrealistic ninja
expectation from data scientists from
everything statistic data analysis
engineering business everything
presentation
so is there science dying out i would
say no
i think that if there is an unrealistic
expectation from data scientists it
means the data science is not dying out
but needs to be redefined reformulated
as task as a job if you realize you're
looking for a ninja as a manager so
maybe you don't
you need more than one person maybe you
don't need a data scientist maybe you
need other other titles as well and i
think data science is not dying out it's
time that data science is becoming
mature and we should define it all of us
where we work at as data scientists or
as manager
what is data science so
i think that data science of course has
overlapped with other fields like it has
overlapping business with data analysis
with mlaps and engineering
um i mean if you have an answer well
mine probably go oh what is that overlap
it's smaller than the other one i mean
forget that i would just put four
circles there to give a message there
are overlaps and um it is fine and it's
normal every job has overlap with some
other jobs but i think that as a data
manager if you
you shouldn't look for ninja who can do
all of these things yeah so that
shouldn't be the focus and i think you
shouldn't focus on the specific parts
and overlaps if you are just
like actually
like concentrating on the overlap of
engineering and data science or business
and data science then
maybe you don't need a data scientist or
maybe you're looking at the wrong like
you're just like very narrow looking
very narrow and then define who you
exactly need and if data science title
fits their role
and as data scientists i really think
that you should define what kind of data
scientists you want to be
because there are data scientists that
they are actually more closer to the
business they they can like work with
businesses stakeholders understand the
problem translating in their data
scientists that they have engineering
skills and they can work more like
closer to that overlap and i think it is
fine or data scientists have fantastic
mathematical statistical like knowledge
so i think that you should define that
for yourself which which kind of data
sciences we want to be and i think in
interviews and hiring process you should
communicate that with your um with your
interviews and also from both sides of
course from the people who are hiring
but also this should be discussed in
interviews okay what do you understand
as data science job
what data scientists should do what team
do you have do you have engineers there
do you have data analysts there do you
have the product owners and product
managers there so this is very important
to understand what would be your task as
data scientists i want to finish the
talk like um here
thank you a lot and we are actually
hiring
data scientists who should do my mlf now
we are hiring data scientists but also
data analysts
in in my team so contact me if you are
looking for a job
thank you
great that's um that's really good and i
actually i was a data scientist before
and i do have like some kind of some of
the things resonate with me and i really
wonder like um do you have any opinion
about the hiring process now for for
data scientists like do you think there
is um what what like anything that you
think is not a good practice or anything
that's good yeah any opinion
yeah opinion of course i have everything
but um i think that um and we have not
just for data science in general and i
am tech in industry we have like this
very frustrating long process of hiring
with a lot of like i don't know text
tech challenges many
interviews and i think it's not okay i
think it's a lot of like wasting time of
the candidates but also the people who
interview and hire and i think that's
not just a specific for data science i i
personally don't like it and i think
it's not healthy and good but in general
for data science i think as i said the
problem is that it's very unclear in
hiring process when i hear from other
people like going to true hiring
processes that what is really their task
and what is needed from them and i think
that's yeah
not good
yeah so we have a question from the
audience uh should companies hire statis
statisticians instead of data scientists
yeah
statistician is this
statisticians i don't know how to
pronounce that but yeah
statisticians statisticians
um so i think um
what i try to make as a point here is
actually like that um you should really
see what you need i i don't know what
that company needs i mean um if
i mean statisticians not necessarily
should be able to code a python
not necessarily i mean some do but not
all so i think that um that it really
depends what the company needs yeah
yeah
so i think that's it for the questions
thank you so much
thank you